foreign
[Music]
took their name from Missouri and Osage
Rivers
Ka
children
of the middle Waters
move said the great white father
[Music]
there are many so many hungry wolves
can you find the wolves in this picture
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Our Lives
are the sum of our choices
[Music]
I cannot escape the past
this mission of yours
trust you
the world is changing
truth is Vanishing War
a long time friend
you've no idea the power I represents
it knows your story
and How It Ends
listen to me the world's coming after
you
his fate is written shall we write yours
too if anything happens to them there's
no place
for that
Ethan what's your objective
what's your ultimate objective
your life will always matter more to me
than my own
none of our Lives can matter More Than
This Mission I don't accept that anymore
[Music]
foreign
can I come to your house tonight sure
do you have anything big planned just a
giant blowout party with all the Barbies
and planned choreography in a bespoke
song you should stop by so cool
it's the best day ever it is the best
day ever and so is yesterday and so is
tomorrow and every day for now forever
do you guys ever think about dying
when my heart breaks some things have
been happening that might be related
cold shower falling off my roof and my
heels are on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
what do I have to do you have to go to
the real world
and go back to your regular life or you
can know the truth about the universe
choice is now yours the first one the
high heel you have to want to know okay
do it again
[Music]
I'm coming with you okay
wow this is the real world what's going
on why are these men looking at me yeah
they're also staring at me
[Music]
that's impossible if this got out this
could mean extremely weird things for
our world
catastrophe
Barbies since we were like five years
old
no one rests until this doll is back in
a box
[Music]
humans only have one ending get that
Barbie
[Music]
atheists live forever
no I won't let you do just one
appendectomy but I'm a man but not a
doctor can I talk to a doctor you are
talking to a doctor I need a clicky pen
No a sharp thing no there he is Doctor
somebody gets security
[Music]
is Bobby if you're still in doubt
thank you passing you into Mr Wayne no
please don't stop I think you're here
now Barry
so you're saying you could travel back
in time
hey Bruce I can fix things I can save
people I can save my mom save your
parents
you can also destroy everything
I love you too so how was it this week
how's school Google was good
oh
this is mad trippy dude this is
catastrophic
this world must die
I'm not gonna lose there again
foreign
let's get nuts
we're in Uncharted Territory
we try not to die
are you ready ready let's go
[Music]
we have fancy friends
yeah it was an Uber
exec
in 213 BC
our committee skill to the dial
that could change the course of history
foreign
[Music]
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
rated PG-13 only in theaters June 30th
tickets on sale now
it's a peaceful place
no
why not
you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven
10 years ago today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
detonated a nuclear warhead in Los
Angeles
the past as long as AI is a threat
we will never stop hunting mountains
this is a fight for our very existence
whatever's in there they're sure worried
about someone getting in
yeah we're getting out
[Music]
we're the same
we can't go to heaven
because you're not good
[Music]
and I'm not a person
to locate the weapon yeah it's a key
belt
I do one with the track
[Music]
we are this close to winning the war
execute her or we go extinct
foreign
[Music]
thank you
what
what your mother never told you you were
royalty the women in our family have the
mighty power to turn into giant Kraken
what now Ruby you're a princess
address the crowd
I think
I am having a panic attack
okay Ruby have it completely totally
ordinary day you got this
[Music]
I feel like a freak ow I just want to be
Ruby Gilman normal teenager oh boo
where's the fun in that you have powers
beyond your imagination
are the protector of all the oceans
creatures it's up to you to stop the
evil mermaids but people love mermaids
of course they do people people are
stupid
show me how to use my power are you
ready
see what you're capable of body armor
almost
it's time to go big
uh we're still on for our tutoring
session later right oh
wow anything for my algae Bay you can do
what no I mean bro
algebra like you're my brother you're my
math brother
I think I like the first one better
[Music]
today I teach at times about a place
called Africa
did you say our mom has come to Queens
over there
means that we
royalty
[Music]
you don't love me
afternoon
I need my wife
even if we have the part you and me us
have one heart
[Music]
nothing but that can keep me from it
thank you
oh misty you must ain't got no Kinfolk
around these parts all I had was my
sister
she was the only one ever loved me
[Music]
it's time for you to see the world
there's gonna be some changes made put
it on this ain't me hush we need to look
like we belong let's see the smile and
come
oh sweet and loving God
now we're talking
[Music]
dear Celie we have more than just kings
and queens
we are at the center of the universe
thank you
wait
I should warn you before you step inside
the house this could change the course
of your entire life I'm not afraid of a
couple goes
you say that now
this Mansion is unhinged
these ghosts definitely don't want to
leave
death clerks around every corner
yeah
God give us a break there's so many bad
people in the world haunt them amen
I do like surprises is anybody else
seeing this
we're gonna fight whether we like it or
not or else we're stuck here for
eternity
if this comes down to an exorcism
room
for one
[Music]
friend was mugged he was tall he had
hair that was sticking out of a what a
top hat yup Top Hat yes yeah yeah it's
like Top Hat you would pull a rabbit out
of it probably uh eyes they were a bit
uh something nice like a raccoon they
sit back
and he was smiling like yeah like that
exactly is this the man who mugged you
wow you just did that just now
welcome to Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria
where fantasy and fun come to life hit
it guys
[Music]
if you're watching this video
it means you've been selected as
Freddy's newest security guard
hello
we're going to have so much fun together
[Music]
look you've had a good career
I don't think you're a big bad Master
spy
[Music]
I think you just
messed up
I think you might have been angry at
what's going on the Russians attack
the election
were you surprised to see us today
is my partner what partner Wally Taylor
hey how are you
we have a search warrant for your house
oh my goodness okay
would you like to see it yes please
125 pounds you guys flatter me
I have a sense of humor I was on your
driver's license that's right
okay well I lied don't we all
reality
what if I said that you printed out
classified information
that document was made its way outside
of NSA
and the most likely candidate
is you
I think you know a lot more than what
you're telling us at this point
I'm trying to deploy I'm not trying to
be a whistleblower that's crazy
now why I'm here is to figure out the
why
behind this look I'm here
reality reality reality
was there something that just
pushed you over the edge on this
hello it's Dad I'm getting out soon
[Music]
mom ask Dad for the money I'll handle it
I need money Tyler
well maybe if you let me see him I might
be a little more generous
[Music]
in the time I have left I would like to
spend it with you I'll do it on one
condition you pay me rent
oh my God you're still so beautiful
you're a tenant that's it
[Music]
since I've seen this place let's stay
filled with bad memories I'm not that
guy anymore
[Music]
I'm tired of being picked on all the
time I'm gonna take you somewhere you
always have to protect yourself
Big Daddy Bulldogs in town huh think
that's a good idea you're an addict
I'm gonna ask you what
you one more time or what don't come in
here now like there's some hero because
you're not
know watch me
I promise I will never let them harm you
again
I know none of us will make up for who I
was or what I did but let me be your
father for once
how did you go to jail which time wait
how many times did you go to prison more
than I care to remember
well it looks like this is home for the
night
goddamn win
Clarence
local officials have declared a
Statewide emergency as these
unprecedented storms continue to rain
sure got a Bus full of prisoners heading
our way got caught in the storm we need
a place to hunker down until it's safe
watch on your best behavior while we're
here
a few things straight you're in my house
now I will not hesitate to shoot you if
I have to y'all don't think this is
cruel and unusual right here
you hear that
can you please tell me how I alligator
got in your damn police station storm
brought him in could be infested with
him by now if you want to survive the
night we're gonna have to find a way to
get along keep an eye on him that's a
Bonafide cop killer right there
he's been alive
you got one shot Sheriff
here to taste like chicken
[Music]
welcome ladies I'm Jasper McDaniel I'll
be your pilot this is awesome
no clothes this bag looks just like mine
we have to call Jasper there is
something off about him I say we do one
just one you make me drop like red
foreign
if we call anyone she's dead we need to
handle this we're going to get a call in
a minute
you're gonna answer the phone read
exactly what I wrote
we have what you want but we also have a
very particular set of skills skills
that make us a nightmare for people like
you let our friend go now but if you
don't you will find you and we will kill
you
that was awesome
[Music]
what next
oh gets real she's crazy
we were free but we had no place to be
free
Lord help me reach my peace of the
promised land
protect me on this journey
routers
[Music]
do you want us we're all equals here
get on down
I got him
this is what we're gonna do
come on get the sheriff and bring them
here
I'm saying guard this being pole guard
him
Tommy Walsh
here we are you me
guy out in the horse
you know this white folk ain't coming
back just because they don't want to
look at you don't mean I can't see
you'll always be a slave to the white
man
you'll always be asleep have you been on
this side keep your mouth shut stay away
behind me for the color of my skin get
to hang you for what you did you
you're my boss
I had to learn as a black woman living
in this damn white world
that I got to work three times it's hard
to get one-fifth of what I deserve
after the walking
dead back for those that can't fight for
themselves it looks like we believe in
the same thing and I forgot just go
about it differently
together
I didn't get a piece of my Promised Land
didn't get the river slow and milk and
honey
be buried out here and I think you
missed some Jamie now yeah
baby girl you with dangerous water
you can be a hero
[Music]
the glory of it
Tommy Watson colored girl
it's more washed
damn that's not a headline here before
[Music]
foreign
bingo
[Music]
so beautiful
oh thanks I
[Music]
you are the most amazingly beautiful
demon I have ever seen
I am not a demon I am mafika the soul of
the forest wow
why have you dressed baths here strange
lady offered me a big reward to find a
special Reef
in the forest behind the dark Mountain
[Music]
did you find the tree
and where is this peasant loser there
[Music]
do you realize how illegal this is
this human is no different than all the
others he will betray you
incredible
Lucas wasn't the source of life
[Music]
there's only one way to stop this evil
strike first
[Music]
go and never return
I love how no matter where you look you
see goodness
but you have made the same mistake I
made once
in the forest alike
fire and hatred
Without End
[Music]
hi my name is Susie Wallace I want to
solve the unsolvable I want to bring
resolution to the most haunting
Mysteries why are you smiling just my
natural expression what is it Sophie
out of Cox have been missing for two
days when the world has a lot of hate
it's time to meditate I'm gonna be
famous when I solve this case and become
a big hero I can't wait
it doesn't matter if you have five
suspects or 500 more often than you
think the culprit is right under your
nose
yeah
I'm Susie
Susie Ohio's own Nancy Drew
it's through your investigation
I remember learning about heroes in
school but I never thought I'd be
sitting next to one I just got jealous
did you get chills I just got chills
with everybody else in the world we wear
masks not with you Susie never change
okay
it was wrong about you even though you
saved the day you still have no social
life
thank you
easy Susie I promise I'm not going to
tell anybody what I found I have no idea
what you're talking about Jesse was
wearing this half the day disappeared
you can tell me what happened
life takes unexpected twists
you're following me
I found more DNA evidence really it
could be the best criminal in the world
but you cannot outrun science
a new tragedy has struck even the most
perfect plans don't always work out
you're my prime suspect my guys
following you for weeks
but eventually a solution will present
itself
on June 16th
wait hold up I know I left this door see
the horror film
preview audiences are calling a killer
experience
no thank you probably runs on racism
[Music]
in your predicament the black character
is always the first to die I will spare
your lives if you've sacrificed the
person you've deemed the blackest guys I
can prove them not the blackest prove it
I thought black Twitter was a type of
seasoning I like Jimmy Fallon without
the roots and wrong I voted for Trump
what
twice
up it's time to die
[Music]
cops
[Applause]
we need a plan please get the weapons
wait chili powder girl what I'm gonna do
cook sorry
everybody everybody
dance time
[Music]
can we just go lock the doors get down
I'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot has happened since My Big Fat
Greek Wedding
my father passed away and His Last Wish
was for us to visit his childhood
Village and reconnect with our Roots so
we're having a reunion we're going to
Greece oh yeah
[Music]
anybody by the name of sulaki on his
flight
Aristotle what I didn't know you were
going to be here you're doing here they
had an amazing date
she ghosted him
you are the protocols family we are
related to your Papa's Cup who was
married to my great great Yaya sister
sister-in-law
I learned Bula I will be your favorite
I promised my dad I would find his best
friends I know them do they still live
here no how do we find them they will
come for the reunion did they tell you
they're coming no
there's no other bedrooms family
sleepover
one reunion
we'll never forget to
man no I am surprised but I am not
surprised because I'm never surprised
you lost me
you dreamed about Aristotle last night
how did you know Greek Voodoo bam I
remember your story I really need to
find my dad's friends Angelo and I are
on it okay bye
[Music]
you're the head of the family now I
can't really Day drink like this don't
worry a lady is never drunk
pick the one we have for dinner oh thank
you uh I'm a vegetarian
no
[Music]
we got these problems
[Applause]
[Music]
I am finding being alive fascinating
[Laughter]
[Music]
people think they know my story but this
is our story
see a second coach you're on the team
here nah but I could be if you're lucky
me and my boys we've been balling with
each other since we was like 10. call
ourselves a Fab Four let's go
we can win you a state championship
guaranteed
when they were young I was just trying
to find good kids and they all kind of
balanced each other out really both his
parents addicts his big brother took him
in saved his little brother's life yeah
we just want [__] I work off a little
bit of this baby fat Drew was born with
basketball in his blood I picked LeBron
because he has skills and he was a good
kid his mom just wants to spot where he
can be safe and not get me any trouble
come on pause Denzel we value all the
talent you boys are gonna bring to this
school oh my goodness look at y'all
cannot tell me
which one are y'all supposed to be
Carlton oh stop you
price one slice you may be seeing the
beginnings of something special here in
Akron watch out you watch out maybe you
see some new faces this is Mr Travis
Travis you're so damn good and they know
it in your business
make sure that doesn't tear him apart
what's it like coaching the best high
school player in the country
play some defense
sorry can't all be composing one what
you said to me how successful you become
depends on how well you manage pressure
he's not just your player he's your son
too talk to each other for the whole
season
what happens if nobody wants me a whole
lot more than just basketball
I wanted to make great players out of
you Dad more than a great man that'll
last a lot longer
we here she didn't know we'll be capable
of
when you look back at this time in your
lives it won't be the stats
to be that person next to you
did you make the time you had together
right now I'm not thinking about the
future I'm thinking about my brothers
[Applause]
running all my life
[Music]
to stop doing this
is
[Music]
foreign
ladies what's the name the Miracles
first prize two tickets to lures best of
luck he's so fun
eyes
what do you want to be going to Lord for
anyway I always wanted you to go there
if you go to that door don't please
bother coming back miracles happen there
he could speak how are you Chrissy my
mother is dead I'm in a place I swore I
would never come back to I I wouldn't
have recognized you 40 years we'll do
that do you I'd say yep mixed yes but
great to have her back marvelous not
even marvelous
congratulations you're coming to Lourdes
who's gonna have to do the cooking in
the cleaning not me I can tell you
that's your job what will I do on my own
I'll be back before you know it be weird
[Music]
here's I am sharing with you is there
only one bed yeah I wouldn't trust I am
not my mother I ain't got the truth
oh yeah
we're ready I'm not
why did you leave leave I was banished
Eileen
I loved you and you left okay how did
you came home can you ever forgive me
[Music]
you don't come to Lourdes for a miracle
Island you come to the strength to go on
when there is no America you're still
alive I'm not just about but there's
always hope peace that's what I hope for
think I had me America well I actually
missed you
this is the story of Alejandro
father gave him everything but she had a
recurring dream of Alejandro leaving the
safe world she created where it faced
the dangers he tried so hard to keep him
from
uh Alejandro Martinez yes Mr Khalil is
ready for you thank you
thank you okay you don't have a while
you have a month to find someone to
cosign your visa and if you don't you
have to leave the US I started
freelancing for this lady I'm late I'm
no I'm
not that's one that's one that's
the squirrels but why not they go very
nicely with the salad do I don't like I
need educating on fine cuisine
yeah you think this lady can sponsor you
I I mean we'll see we'll see
is this your dream making toys yeah help
me curate an exhibition
the thing is you can't take money right
now you must find a sponsor and pay fees
who earn money the maze is impossible to
navigate wait I mean this sucks so much
for you
I'm barely keeping the flow your boss is
a monster I need to get paid
that's a nightmare none of those options
my question if you are ready for this
job why are you making everything so
difficult
foreign
journeying into the unknown
it sounds Brave
it's so simple Alejandro this is it the
sky's the limit
[Music]
oh El Salvador
who pooses yes and those nuns they
killed in the 80s right so
got some big plans
you expect me to cut my hand to bring
some vigilanteed ghosts back from his
grave man you crazy
play the damn game
[Music]
I saw them die
what do you know about devilro the
children's ghost story most ghost
stories some basis and Truth The Deadly
night happened right out there yeah
Michaels
I'm gonna take your life yes baby
the witch brought him back from the dead
to seek his Revenge come home come home
curse the bloodline of all involved
pause
my bloodline
come home to us
oh
I wanted to summon the so-called
Boogeyman of the sound
some have dubbed him the Lua Keeper of
the graveyard The Giver of Life and the
master of the Dead
[Music]
foreign